meine Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen bei wer weiß
mehr unser Kandidat der Graf hat ein
bisschen Bammel vor dieser großen
Aufgabe die heute bewältigen Gottes will
ist noch früh wie du weißt wir haben
immer ein Spezialthema bei wer weiß mehr
unser heutiges Spezialthema
wahrscheinlich hast du ein bisschen
Ahnung heißt der Graf oh das ist ja ein
schönes Thema ja bei WWM wir hoffen dass
du dich ein wenig auskennst ja ich ja
dann fangen mal an pass auf wir fangen
mal an du bist konzentriert du bist
vorbereitet e du bist ja dein Leben hat
ich auf dieses Quiz vorbereitet muss
sagen ja mein ganzes Leben lang meine
letzten 26 Jahre mein ganzes Leben lang
habe ich nur darauf gewartet dass das
jetzt passiert so jetzt passiert dafür
hast du alles getan pass auf also
Konzentration die Frage lautet wie viel
Wochen war dein Erfolgsalbum große
Freiheit auf Platz 1 pass auf es gibt
vier Antwortmöglichkeiten a 15 Wochen B
21 Wochen C 22 Wochen oder D 23 Wochen
weißt du es ich weiß es okay
23 das willst Du einloggen also D23 ich
tippe D23 24 Wochen ist nämlich noch
einer gewesen und den haben wir quasi
nicht gebrochen diesen Rekord das war
irgend so was internationales also 23
Wochen diesen Pausen die es da gab war
es auf Platz 1 aber damit das
erfolgreichste deutschsprachige Album ja
ja das das erfolgreichste
deutschsprachige Album ja das war 23
Wochen auf Platz 1 okay D eingelogt er
sagt es sind 23 Wochen und das ist
richtig Wahnsinn pass auf aber das war
ja noch letztlich einfach das war die 50
€ Frage ne das war quasi die 50 € Frage
oh Gott wenn man der Graf sucht auf
Google ja da gibt es eine erste
Suchseite da tauchst du relativ oft auch
auf aber nicht nur es gibt einen
Suchbegriff der wenn man der Graf sucht
auch auf der Seite 1 unter der Graf
auftaucht und jetzt ist es ist die Frage
ist es
a
buchdoppelpunkt der Graf der Grafen ist
es
B die elegante Lösung der Graf
säulentank
ist es
C war mal
hier Kritik der Graf
Meister so oder ist es D richtig nein
der graft Tank der graftank unter den
flachtanks ah Quatsch das sind jetzt
nicht alle vier Antworten na eine davon
ist richtig eine davon ist auf Seite 1
der Suchbegriff der suchanfrag von der
Graf im Moment das kann ich natürlich
nächst wieder
nein kannst du kannst du noch mal kurz
Joker den kannst du einsetzen den könn
ich dir jetzt geben wie viel wie viele
Fragen kommen noch es sind also noch
eine kommt das ist die vorlte Frage ja
dannke dann möchte ich gerne Million ja
ich bin Wahnsinn von 50 € jetzt schon
bei 800 000 oder so ist dein Talent ja
unfassbar wie schnell das geht sollte
immer so sein ich hätte gerne den
50 J gut dann bleibt
nur Theaterkritik der Graf a Hausmeister
oder der Graf Tank unter den flachtanks
Quatsch jetzt den da ist also der
Hausmeister ja oder der
Flachtank ich würde sagen der
Hausmeister okay du lockst ein ich locke
den Hausmeister ein er hat den
Hausmeister eingelogt und wir sehen ihm
die Nerv Nervosität an es ist furchtbar
es ist aber der graft Tank odter den
flachtanks ch Quatsch doch was ist das
denn das ist keine Ahnung das ist
irgendein Tank es gibt einen Grab
Flachtank ja was ist das denn we ich do
nicht a bin ich nicht vorgedogen wenn
ich zu Hause bin werde ich im Interview
werde ich im Interview werde ich
Internet suchen Graf Flachtank ja komm
wenn du der Graf eingibst kommst auf ich
geb immer Unheilig ein und guck da was
ja genau da bist Du natürlich h 100%
aber bei der GRA pass auf wir kommen zur
letzten Frage du darfst weitermachen
aussweise aussweise okay du hast eine
eigene
Community ja wie viel Mitglieder hat
deine
Community a
20.000 B 30.000 C 40.000 oder D 50.000
also ich kenne meine Community Community
bei Facebook da bin ich du h do auf
deiner Webseite aber die ist doch
verlinkt mit Facebook ja ja trotzdem
hast du das ist eine andere Zahl als auf
Facebook s ganz andere Zahlen weil man
wenn man auf deiner Fanseite auf
Facebook Fan ist muss man nicht Mitglied
in deiner Community
sein
und du beschwerst dich dass ich nicht
weiß was ein grabfachtank ist ja nein
ich muss das ja erstmal verstehen also
bei mir so ich gucke ja immer überall
rein und dann landest du bei Facebook
weil da hast ja dann die ganzen Einträge
und direkten Reaktionen immer also
ja noch mal bitte 30 40 also a 20 B 30 C
40 oder D würde ich jetzt raten würde
ich jetzt ratente ich sag mal 30 30 du
lockst B30 ein ich locke D also B B 30
ein B wie Berta 30 okay B wieberta
30.000 ist eingeloggt und das ist leider
falsch wie viel haben wir 40.000 40000
40 000 das ist eine Menge für eine
eigene komm alter Schwede noch ja ja
siehst du mal wie peinlich ne peinlich
aber das si man kann nicht alles ne all
ich Ken den Flachtank nicht danke schön
trotzdem vielen
Dank WWM ja danke schön danke schön kein
Problem beim nächsten Mal noch besser
vorbereiten ja herrlich Biss ein
Schätzchen und mehr wer weiß mehr gibt
es z.B mit Silbermond und mit K1 und
einer bzw eine von beiden die kennen
sich oder der kennt sich richtig gut aus
und die der andere nicht so gut also
guckt euch selber mal an bis dann bleibt
dran